I've seen the first six episodes my big
complaint is I have not seen seven
through ten so I need you both to do
something about this for me
um
being serious so The Season's 10
episodes for each of you uh which is
your favorite episode of season 10
episode number of season 10 and why yeah
I would say nine is my favorite if I'm
remembering correctly uh nine is my
favorite and I cannot tell you why
um I can say six is also a favorite just
because
I I'm really proud of the storytelling
uh uh yeah I will say uh episode four
definitely has a has a very special
place in my heart
um because it deals with uh it deals
with with a moment when
um when characters and specifically my
character uh you know feels like like
they are not up to the challenge and
that they can't possibly do what is
being asked of them and and they need to
find a way to do what is being asked of
them because nobody else can do it and I
feel like that's something that is going
to resonate with a lot of people and
that definitely resonated a lot with me
in the moment um shooting it with in my
own life and um so I'm excited to see
that again with the world when it
premieres so definitely episode four
yeah Anson just told me that he
rehearsed on weekends for episode nine
but would not tell me what happens or
what it's about so I'm so curious what
that means if he's like rehearsing on
weekends
Anson's very devoted very professional
very good listen more devoted my
goodness
the things uh uh what are you allowed to
tease about your character's journey in
season two even though I could say
things I'm not going to what are you
allowed to say
um I'll I'll start with that I'll just
say you know we got to we got to see you
know this wonderful Hotshot pilot that
that I think uh
I think for the most part everybody
really fell in love with
um which which made me really happy and
um you know was a testament to the
writers and to the crew um but but
throughout every episode she was a bit
of it and you know the Legacy characters
got a lot of the story time um as they
should have in in season one and in
season two we're gonna see more Ortegas
um and see kind of
um moments where she does not
necessarily feel like she can
fill the shoes of the Hotshot pilot but
indeed she can and how does she get to
that and we also see her backstory as a
soldier which is something that I knew
about because
um you know our showrunners told me
about that from from the gecko in season
one and we're gonna we're gonna
definitely touch on that and and and see
how that impacts and has impacted her
relationship with her crew and so I'm
excited for for fans to get to see more
of her backstory yeah uh I will say uh
we sort of with Uhura we pick up almost
exactly where we've left off sort of in
her personal Arc of her uh uh morning
her her best friend her dearly departed
um and we really focus on
Humanity with her with her story I feel
like
um Uhura serves in in this series she
serves as sort of a lens as how the
audience receives this uh uh show and
she's sort of uh uh getting to know this
crew as the audience is getting to know
this crew and she's getting to know
herself as the audience is getting to
know her
um and yeah it's very specific to her
and very special to her and we just see
how she continues to grow into the
person we know she's becoming and and
what it took to get her there and it was
not a a pretty rose line white picket
fence walked down the driveway it's it's
it's a crawl and and a a real journey
hard fought and and we watch her through
that and we're rooting for her the whole
way through but um yeah we we watch her
grow and continue to just do the human
thing of processing and taking it one
day at a time and seeing how it goes and
and having faith I think that the
difference between the first season and
the second season is in the second
season we see Uhura more comfortably
lean on her crew in moments where she
doesn't feel supported within herself
and that's a beautiful thing to see
um and yeah we just sort of expand on
that and and that's where I'll leave it
on that note I already have to stop I'm
just gonna say I really can't wait to um
see the rest of the episodes and good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
today thank you thank you
it feels like